mais moi je trouve effectivement de plus
en plus beau tiercé des lèvres il a
refait sur les bourses sont de plus en
plus et la fessée sur lui et moi c'est
un binôme en fait et maintenant il est
beaucoup plus sérieux c'est vrai
d'accord il est beaucoup plus
l'animateur oui il a fait de la
chirurgie esthétique
ah oui d'accord pas oui quand même et ça
lui va très bien battre amassé russie
qui sont les foodies quand c'est réussi
s'ils réussissent ils verde je n'ai
jamais entendu autant de conneries ça
c'est dit il ya eu un naufrage de 15 ans
et une peut que remonter la pente
l'art c'est moche la parole on va
remonter quand même dommage
bailly en grèce ben moi je me régale un
très bon dans leur vie excellent dans le
système bella je l'avais en ligne sur
domenech je vais mais ce qui s'est passé
les jours marqués en fait je vais mieux
je vais pas vous mentir c'est vrai que
c'est vrai qu'ils l'année dernière
c'était un peu compliqué voilà ce n
était pas en forme
je pense que comme vous comme beaucoup
de gens il ya eu le confinement qui
accueille des conques ont des
conséquences sur tout le monde et j'ai
dit c'est que j'étais aimé et elle a eu
la bonne année j'étais triste d'être ici
c'est vrai c'est vrai peut-être a changé
j'étais triste j'étais un peu éteint web
et après ça dans la vie c'est maman qui
arrive les choses vont mieux ça faisait
un petit garçon qui me qui bat et qui
m'a forcé à être en forme avec brown moi
je suis là je suis très en forme sud de
l'irlande vanter je fais si cette heure
de sport par semaine ne mange pas je
prêtais la femme dit avant ils péter
mackay
non mais et après c'est vrai que après
c'est toujours pareil on me fait
confiance je me fais confiance on a un
beau projet pour le mois d'avril début
avril sous pression pour en parler
encore mais ça va être très belle soirée
grande soit au courant ça crève les yeux
et c'est vrai que plus ça va plus ça
vaille mieux ça va comme moi et moi non
mais ça va dans un sens et l'a6 dans
l'autre sens quand ça va mal
généralement quand les balles et
j'emmerde arrive c'est souvent en
escadrille et quand le bonheur arrive
c'est aussi attention jaton lola